تطورات اذا متلاحقه في المواقف الدوليه
بعدما اصدرت الدائره التمهيديه الثانيه
بالمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكرتي توقيف
في حق الرئيس الروسي
ومفوضه حقوق الطفل في الرئاسه الروسيه
ماريا بلوفا اتابع ردود الفعل بعد من
موسكو من هناك مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
وبنكييف مراسل الجزيره حسن الشوبكي وابدى
معك امين درغامي فيما يتعلق بردود الفعل
حيال هذا القرار من قبل المحكمه الدوليه
عبد القادر اليوم روسيا توعدت محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه بانها ستخضع لعقوبات
عليها وعلى اعضائها بما فيهم القضاه الذين
شاركوا في تلك التحقيقات وقالت بانها من
الجدير ان يتم فتح حوار مع الدول الصديقه
لروسيا من اجل انشاء محكمه
مؤسساتيه تكون بديله عن محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه هذا ما صدر على لسان نائب رئيس
مجلس الاتحاد الروسي قسطنطين كوساتشيف
وذلك طبعا في اطار او في سياق الردود
الروسيه على هذا القرار الذي صدر عنه
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه التي تراها روسيا
بانها مسيسه ولا يخضع او لا تخضع كل
الاطراف سواء في الازمه او حتى الاطراف
الدوليه
المساءله امامها باعتبار ان روسيا ترى ان
هذه المحكمه اغفلت
عدد كبير من الخروقات وبين قوسين الجرائم
التي ارتكبتها اوكرانيا منذ عام 2014 في
اقليم دومباس اضافه الى انها لم تسائل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كما ذكر بيان
السفاره الروسيه في واشنطن ايضا صباح
اليوم لم تسائلها في بعض الجرائم ايضا بين
قوسين التي تتهم واشنطن بارتكابها سواء في
العراق او افغانستان او غيرها من الدول بل
روسيا ترى بان ما يحدث الان وهيستيريا كما
قال رئيس مجلس الدوما
فالودن صباح اليوم قال بان هذه الاوراق
التي تصدر عن المحكمه الدوليه غير ملزمه
بالنسبه لروسيا وان اي تهجم على الرئيس
الروسي سيعد بمثابه تهجم على الدوله
الروسيه روسيا لا تعترف بهذه المحكمه كما
نعلم هذه القرارات بالنسبه لها غير ملزمه
والان لربما هناك بوادر على ان روسيا
ستتجه نحو فرد عقوبات على اعضاء هذه
المحكمه على القضاه وهي التي كانت طبعا
صباح اليوم عبر بيان السفاره الروسيه في
واشنطن قد يعني انتقدت الولايات المتحده
التي كانت قد فرضت عقوبات على المدعيه
العامه السابقه بنسوده حينما فتحت تحقيقات
في ما توصف بالجرائم الامريكيه التي ارتكب
الجيش الامريكي في افغانستان وطبعا كل ذلك
كان ايضا في اطار رد روسي على
تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن امس
الذي راى في قرار محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
بانه مبرر باصدار طبعا هذه المذكره
باعتقال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
حسنا شبهي ماذا عن الصوره في كييف عقب هذه
المذكره من قبل محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
نعم عبد القادر هنالك حاله ترحيب واسعه
ولا يوجد مسؤول لاوكرانيا لم يتحدث في هذا
الامر هنالك تصريحات عديده في هذا السياق
وابدؤها بما قاله الرئيس بندمسكي الذي قال
ان المهمه كانت مضنيه وصعبه وللمره الاولى
يتم اتهام الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بانه مجرم حرب واكد زيلينسكي في تصريحات
له بهذا الخصوص بان الرئيس بوتين ليس فقط
متهما كمجرم حرب في هذه القضيه انه يقوم
بعمليات اباده جماعيه في اوكرانيا بعد
اعلانه الحرب عليها واكد
بقوله ان هذا جاء من قرارات دوله
وسماها بالحرب
دوله وقال ان مثل هذه القرارات لا يمكن ان
تاتي الا بموافقه راس الدوله ويقصد بوتين
هذا على صعيد بالنسبه
لاوليكسي دانيلوب سكرتير مجلس الامن
القومي والدفاع الاوكراني قال هنالك بعد
عده ايام او في الاسبوع الحالي سيكون هناك
لقاء بين الرئيس الصيني والرئيس الروسي
وقال ان الصين في وضع صعب او وضع حرج كيف
سيصافح الرئيس الصيني الرئيس
بلاتينيمير بوتين بعد ان تم الاشتباه به
بوصفه مجرم حرب بسبب ترحيل قضيه ترحيل
الاطفال الاوكرانيين ايضا يمكن القول بعبد
القادر بان المدعي العام الاوكراني
اندريه كان قد تحدث وهو صاحب هذا الملف
الذي حمله طيله الشهور الماضيه قال انه
قدم اربعين مجلدا وكذلك اكثر من الف صفحه
واكد المدع العام الاوكراني بان ما قامت
به روسيا هو سرقه لمستقبل وتاريخ اوكرانيا
وانهم يريدون سرقه اطفالنا هذا ما قاله
بالحرف وشدد على ان الجهود يجب ان تستمر
للقاء القبض على بلادي كما قال المدعم
الاوكراني خارج الاراضي الروسيه بالنسبه
للدول الموقعه على ميثاق روما بهذا الشان
والكلام الاكبر كان لرجل الدبلوماسيه
الاول وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمترو
كوليبا الذي قال ان الدول الموقعه على
ميثاق روما قبل نحو 20 عاما ملزمه بان
تلقي القبض على بوتين اذا تواجد على
اراضيها وقال ان المساله ليست من وجهه نظر
قانونيه وحسب بل ايضا من وجهه نظر سياسيه
انه لا يمكن اقامه علاقات مع بوتين واعتبر
بانه ليس فقط مجرم حرب هذا الحديث على
لسان كوليبا ليس فقط مجرم حرب بل انه متهم
بسرقه الاطفال ايضا الاوكرانيين وهنالك
مطالبات اوكرانيه واسعه هنا على صعيد
دبلوماسي وسياسي لان يكون هنالك المزيد من
الدور الاوكراني
لاستعاده هذه هؤلاء الاطفال والنساء الذين
تم ترحيلهم قصريا بموجب ما حدث بعد الحرب
لنتابع عبد القادر ما قاله ديمتروكوليبا
وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا
سيدرجاوي من الان فصاعدا فان جميع الدول
الاعضاء الموقعه على اتفاقيه روما
الاساسيه ملزمه باحتجاز بوت نفسه اذا كان
داخل اراضيها لتنفيذ مذكره المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه من وجهه نظر قانونيه لا
سياسيه لاول مره رسميا وقانونيا الرئيس
بوتين متهم كمجرم حرب وليس كاي مجرم وانما
كشخص يسرق الاطفال ويمكن ان تكون سرقه
الاطفال احدى علامات الاباده الجماعيه
قرار المحكمه يعني انه لا يمكن العوده الى
العلاقات مع بوت